hey guys ride the righteous over here
and I'm Jerry the Jerry I'm Frannie the
fast
no brandy The Price is Right today we're
gonna check out the trailer for The
Human Centipede part three so excited
I'm not even gonna try and sugar cuz I
love him concept of the human centipede
do a lot it sounds great
I really liked the first we don't want
if you tell someone they're connecting
human beings together through the mouth
and butthole how could you not want to
like take a look at what that is yeah
you know it's like a sideshow attraction
just like I kind of got a look at it
yeah you'd at least want to Google an
image
[Music]
is almost too disgusting to describe
No
the unthinkable has become chapter it
looks medically accurate to the most
notaries will be franchise
[Music]
Wow centipede 3 final sequence this is
exactly what America needs I love the
direction of this film I don't know oh
it's the [ __ ] like grindhouse type of
vibe to it I guess that's the way to go
like yeah it's the next step in meta I
guess so yeah I mean it's like I just
learned that word people know I don't
know this next meta like it depends
because I can't tell now which which
what version of what universe is is
taking place Oh totally see those of you
who don't know it's like the first movie
is just in its own universe it's just a
movie like a narrative movie that way
and then the second movie takes place in
the real world where the human centipede
exists as a film and it's just a film
and this guy really loves that film and
wants to recreate it so I don't know
what step they've taken for the third
place
well good the original doctors in this
one yeah that actor yes it's probably in
the real world too and he wanted more
notoriety it's like an exploitation film
that looks awesome
yeah yeah I love the cheesy acting and
stuff it's like they're going way bigger
this time all those poor guys in that
prison but they go hundred people so
they said only a hundred people in a
prison no no no a hundred person said if
you wanted it alone nice and you see
that line is that wasn't that last shot
of all of them wind up together yeah and
their orange jumpsuit yeah yeah the
comas hot no come on
someone's sticking their face in your
bubble no it's not not my jam not my
damn mining
but it's worth trying in real life
subscribers go ahead and try to make a
human centipede the words of Ryan writes
I just appreciate the first move because
it's very different than what I expect
the first one I remember going to the
theaters to see this it was playing at
this little revival house and they only
had like two weekends they were showing
it we went the first weekend it was sold
out so we bought taking his advance to
come back the next weekend and I was the
first time in ages I actually been
really nervous before a movie because I
didn't know what I was gonna see and it
sounded really gruesome and then it was
very different from what I had expected
so like it was just like oh wow I don't
get this experience a lot where it's
like I'm really scared to go in and then
it's it's it's also a surprise you know
yeah yeah I felt that way about about
the purge what I was like wow this is
really original the whole time whole
time I was like this is totally original
I wanted to see you my vision I really
wanted this to take place in one
building instead of an entire city so
anyway thank you guys for mentioning
that trailer result
I mean I'm stoked - I love modern-day
takes on exploitation films well you
know I do appreciate about that about
this film series is that every movie has
been markedly different cuz that's
what's cool yeah you know so like the
tone changes every time they have prout
like the way they're shooting it changes
every time the version of the world even
just a countries and stuff changed at
that time like I appreciate at least
that he's doing that they should have it
take place amongst them much of a
priests like it takes place in a church
but if you guys are new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and you can check out reasons to Jerry
his movie review show and other fun
stuff every once in a while and brandy
price channel go ahead and check that
out independent movie reviews people
don't get that too often you know like
you check out a film and you're like
where's
movie review of this movie but no one's
seen it
brandy saw it nerd rambles oh [ __ ] can I
get a shout-out for my youtube channel
and FB page that stands for a fun
[ __ ] page by the way he has a website
dedicated to hot [ __ ] who are also
fun at the same time rare combo unless
they're drunk that would be awesome
been watching you guys since you had a
thousand subscribers whoa really and now
look as y'all
you want me to give you a shout-out to
your YouTube channel Facebook page what
is it is it nerd rambles this guy does
reviews and reactions